hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
mp.l2-3.8.9 protect the confidentiality
of backup cui at storage locations
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist sp80171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so uh on first glance we're going to
make like a losing contestant on
Jeopardy here you're going to slam the
buzzer and make the wrong guess on this
okay on at first read your gut reaction
is going to be this compliance control
is mandating that your backups are to be
encrypted but the good news is they are
not okay that is not what this control
is all about so you know I have to hand
it to the folks at darzanara who created
this stuff because when they write these
controls the one thing I will say is
they're very careful with their words
and as they should be right I mean the
whole world is watching as they say no
pressure right uh what the focus this
control is on is confidentiality okay
not encryption so that also translates
that backups need to be confidential
they need to be controlled so nobody
gets access to them but encryption uh
believe it or not is just not a part of
the equation so again encryption not so
important to meet this control uh big
take home here uh a simple file copy
process is okay all right because that's
reality for most people or or these most
smaller businesses obviously if what you
really should be doing some sort of an
image based backup but that's just not
the reality in some cases as long as it
meets the specifics of what an assessor
is looking for and for that let's check
out the assessment points so uh on this
one they're really only looking for one
thing they're looking to determine if
the confidentiality of backup cui is
protected at storage locations no
there's nothing about encryption there
it's just it's not there now if you've
got your backup encrypted like most
people do but but not all uh you
probably want to mention that in the
answer but it's not going to get you to
pass the control so again what we would
say is backup Cy is fully encrypted this
is true and backup locations are
controlled and again you may demonstrate
that to an assessor that's probably the
most likely way that you would actually
sort of uh pass this controls with a
demonstration that yep there's the
backups they're in a lock secure server
room there's no way people can get to it
and then you know again they may ask for
any more evidence that will make them
happy in doing so so at on call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this Deep Bars nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped in
their laps like a seagull on a sunny day
and we teach you how to level up and be
a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the buy it
below for links to get help right now if
you love the content we're putting out
here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash the Subscribe button to get
the latest compliance content as soon as
our compliance turns roll it out until
the next compliance tip my friends stay
safe and secure out there and hit us in
the comments below let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]